good afternoon everyone my name is even
hated Smith and I'd like to welcome
YouTube after for another of the BAFTA
TV Croft sessions this time I'll be
speaking with the nominees in the
editing category for both fiction and
nonfiction for anyone who hasn't been to
want to be a better today we've got
about an hour I'll introduce our guests
in a moment then we'll talk for about 45
minutes or so and then we'll open the
floor to any questions or comments that
you may have and to introduce our guests
today first on my right Jett Murphy who
David Bowie in the last five years
then Anna price who edited Louis through
dark state's heroin tan then Dan Roberts
who worked on peaky blinders peered at
Charlotte who worked on the crown and
finally you know knee Galena last time I
saw correct me in Anika Neela janila
sorry um who worked on three girls and
before we get going let's see some
examples of their work wasn't that he
was out of breath he was like
hyperventilating in a way like getting
getting his energy up to sameness to
deliver this song
he was quite stoked like I like to say
in the in the zone and I could see him
through the window that he was really
feeling it me a man on top of his game a
three year veteran of the river bank he
was also a dealer that's something of a
connoisseur of heroin I've definitely
got some dough I got the best up in the
city best up in the tri-state now right
there is that fire you know saying wow
yeah it's kind of pink like a pinkish
looking yeah tiny bit tight pinky gray
cuz it's not straight heroin it's
fentanyl cuz I've heard you can OD on
that oh yeah okay if I did that right
there by myself did I would drop dead
you know I mean and I do I have a
tolerance higher than most people in a
town when I heard I was going to
courtesan I could exactly as you do now
Richie I wanted to stay at home with my
dear favorite sister I wanted the
easiest softer way but in order to grow
up properly you didn't get away from all
of this nonsense
would you like me to let you into a big
please this is not the real world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're not
[Music]
coming to the room with me why
now I'm talking about something
can you talk to me here can talk to you
in private five very different projects
in terms of tone and content but
hopefully over the course of the next
hour we might discover that this sort of
common themes between them I was
thinking about starting by asking what
attracted you for the project then I
thought actually perhaps we could talk
about how you found your way into each
of the projects that you worked on you
know start on the classified pension and
well Philippa Luthor is the director and
she had asked to meet me so I mean it
was very simple that she had seen some
of my previous work and I think she'd
spoken to someone who had worked with me
before so she just called me and I had
read the script I read all three scripts
and Nicole Taylor wrote them so
beautifully because I was really
interested to meet her and I did have a
few sir of em questions about the script
so I urge everyone to be very honest end
up meeting and I sort of felt I had
nothing to lose to sort of say anything
that I had a little bit of a concern
about because the scripts and the story
was obviously so important that you know
there were questions to be asked about
how I felt was going to approach it and
particularly the first episode is really
about the girls but the second episode
is about the police investigation of the
third episode is about the court case
and I really want to know how she was
going to weave the story of the girls to
keep their sort of subjective point of
view in the episodes 2 & 3 because in
the script form they sort of disappeared
even in final final product did a little
bit less screen time so having a very
sort of frank conversation with Philippa
she and Nicole also wanted to weave more
of the subjective point of view of the
girls into the later episodes so we
really found her on the same page and
then she asked me and I was thrilled and
delighted to join them on that journey
it's sort of simple was worth worth
asking the questions
yeah well I moved here 20 years ago to
edit features because my work pradhan
in Canada this American television and I
found that the collaboration between the
editor and director was very curtailed
like they would work with us for a
couple weeks and then the producers
would take over so I moved here and I
was doing the features and I got a call
from my agent saying Steven Daldry wants
to meet you for the crown and I said oh
no I don't do television yet and then I
got another call I was working with
Dennis Davis and he wanted to meet me
and and there was also a bit of fear you
know like being rejected from Steven
Daldry I don't think I could live with
that
so I said no again and then the third
call came a few months later and he
offered me the show without an interview
and at the time I was booked to do Paddy
Considine journeymen so I called Patti
up and I said you know what's going on
and he said well our films been delayed
by five months so you've got that window
so I accepted the crown and I have to
say my life would have been so different
without it working with Steven Daldry
Peter Morgan left bank and Netflix has
been unbelievable and and British
television has never been better so I'm
thrilled to be on the show well I'm not
quite sort of I'm at stage in my career
so my involvement came about it was much
more machiavelli or nuts
I couple years ago I got a really great
break and I worked on a terrific show
called guerrilla John Ridley and the
producers on that were a company called
Fifty Fathoms KT Swindon was the
executive producer and I got on great
with Rebecca expense colleague and they
really thought I'd done good work on
that show and so I was very blunt
I've been a KT swing they've been a
producer on series one of peaky blinders
and I knew it was about to go into
production and I I've been a big fan of
peaky since it's the first episode of
the so yeah it was deeply Machiavelli
said Katie will you be a good word for
me
I bought a big bunch of flowers she the
extent I don't know if they asked if
they were interviewing other people or
other people in mind it worked out I had
a Skype interview with David O'Donnell
from the produce you severely already up
in Liverpool prepping for it and we hit
it off and I got off with the job it was
a dream with um well mine was very easy
I've done several there is there is
before so they asked me if I wanted to
cut this one and it ended up that I
edited all three dark states which I
kind of loved because it was the first
time I've done the whole series with
Lily and as a trio they're slightly
different films but heroin town I
actually cut last met it went out first
so it was partly feeling my way into the
into that theories of feeling my way to
Trump's America and then that one was
seen to encapsulate both the very
pressing current issue of deep personal
stories so it was it was particularly
rewarding for all of us I think
Jade you you really do have to say this
was the most difficult project of your
life otherwise we're gonna be finished
in about ten minutes it was they had its
moments are the most difficult project
of funny thing is Francis is the
director of work many times as I was a
BBC staff editor for 20 years or
something like that and I sort of made a
lot of contacts in the BBC Francis is
one of them and when I went freelance
it's it's the usual thing there I'm
working this person before we get on we
don't try and kill each other in the
cutting room so you know let's do it
again and we've always loved music films
and we've always done lots of different
arts films and current affairs spills
but when the Bowie came up the first one
he said yeah we're gonna say no and when
the second one came up well we had to do
it we sort of it's it's the way it works
for me anyway which is probably a bit
different from you because I I you tend
to work with people who either of heard
of you you know and that's how the berry
thing came about really through my
working with Francis and you know the
work you've done up until that point if
I was rubbish I guess he wouldn't I said
about a commonality between these
programs one of the things that struck
me watching these over the course of the
last week again is any it perhaps seems
like it's stating the obvious but
finding the perfect balance and I want
to stay with you
first a bow in the last five years had
this been the last five years up until
two years ago it might have been
something that perhaps was easier to
find a balance because I always like
coming to an end but what you have is
two final albums
similarly black star yes that our
extraordinary works yes and it's not
something you can just say oh yeah then
he released that and sudden he died yeah
no this is a major work in a canon that
that's already impressive how easy was
it to find that balance of coverage of
the making of that album
all the people involved in that album
and also managing to be able to go back
in time and work through the different
key periods of his career yeah well in
the Bowie's case he was always one for I
think and I think I could say this
that's what you get from listening with
the interviews from everyone he's one
for spinning his own myth and and I
think to some degree that's kind of what
he was doing because I'm sure and that
he probably knew he was going to die
when he was making blacks are I don't
know but you know from from the
interviewees you know there was that
that kind of sense of they were doing
something interesting and different here
and it's kind of keeping on going back
to his earlier work was just a way of
drawing those kind of things which he
kept coming back to on that album and
then they were you know somewhere
obvious something less obvious but and
kind of spinning it into something that
I kind of obsess it's it's almost like
the cumulative effect of it you get the
character of David or whatever through
it if any of us can know that because I
don't know whether we could but there
were you know you do get the sense that
you know here was somebody who was kind
of making something a little bit sort of
different it was the black star so he
was an album that was very different to
anything he'd done before because he
news new musicians and that brought
something out in him in the same way
that Lo and heroes did possibly and
that's I think getting that across and
also having the the human side of it and
the Robert Fox of directors of the
Lazarus play leaving that in as well as
quite quite quite interesting that kind
of works as a kind of a if you if you
like and you get something that was the
idea that you you get all this and then
you get an idea of the person as much as
you can through it but also that
interesting thing of as you saw in that
sequence with with the recording of
Lazarus an artist aware of being at the
end of his life using his work to look
back on that life and employing the
archived footage there
to kind of intersect all those different
elements that's that's yeah that was a
conscious decision on France this part
that you know would inform everything
that went before informs everything that
he is and you know yeah we worked quite
hard at sort of get making that work you
know and yeah it's kind of fun kind of
shelter you know peer I I think of all
the episodes of the Craig structurally
is the one that you've been nominated
for he is in many ways the most
challenging the way that you're shifting
back and forth in time and trying to
find the themes within the present in
the past to link together were there a
lot of discussions that you had with the
team about how to make sure that this
didn't depart it wasn't too much of a
departure from the other episodes in the
series in terms of their linear not
really because Stephen Daldry has his
own vision so and the script was amazing
however I'm glad you mentioned structure
because I restructured most of the show
in the script like I say this
brilliantly written but they had scenes
for instance Prince Charles his first
night when the rain is hitting his bed
there was a kind of a trick see edit and
then you find its young Phillip in the
in the dorm and I thought it wasn't
elegant enough so and also emotionally
sometimes we wanted to stay longer with
one gory and not cut to the other boy so
it was a matter of finding what we
needed when we could switch over
emotionality and finding visual
references to for instance after Prince
Phillip bullies the Queen and puts his
foot down
and informs her that Charles will stay
at Gordon stone we added a shot of
Philip walking out into the hallway and
just showing a little flicker of remorse
and then from that shot we were meant to
cut to young Philip on the obstacle
course and by moving the shot of young
Charles when he's looking in the trophy
cabinet looking at his father as a young
boy with the trophy and it just
connected all three characters and so
visually it went from older Philip to
Charles so the images and compositions
worked but emotionally it just led you
through and allowed you to then go to
young Philip so and although I'm working
with they're all multi oscar-nominated
and winning writers directors producers
they welcome collaboration so it's not
that you're stuck with that script or
stuck with that scene and they want
suggestions you know I'm able to suggest
pickup shots or pickup scenes and and
Stephen is very generous so he kind of
says you have free rein cut it and then
I'll come in and watch it and it's just
such a joy to to hear his reactions or
watch his face when something surprises
him so I'm just very blessed to be
working with him you know you mentioned
earlier about the narrative structure of
three girls and I want to pick a scene
that's in the first episode that you've
been nominated for of the police
interview with the Maine young female
protagonist and we also have Paul k in
the room who who plays her father and
I'm very curious about you were saying
about the focus on her but the
discussions that you had with Philip er
about the cutaways to Paul and the way
that you move back and forth on that
from the shots of the police officer but
particularly port because this this
relationship starting to balance that is
very antagonistic at first because he's
not aware
situation yeah and that had that
character transforms Annie's
relationship with her how you talked
about this the way this would be set up
yeah so the way I feel about she shot up
because the three well Rhea one of the
three girls had started mr. Selfridge
but the other two girls really hadn't
started they were the realist of early
actors so now obviously brilliant and
they've done a lot of stuff since three
girls so one of the things I would say
that the film wanted to do was too much
she kept the girls used to the camera
because Martin Ray was the DOP and he
just was handheld and he came very close
so she didn't want girls sort of a
coiling so what she Phillip decide at
mast they shot these long six-minute
takes so it meant when I got those every
scene it's a little bit like documentary
that I had in every second take might
have done something else the detail of
the hand with Michael I had her and the
third tape would do something else again
so it meant that when we were in she
couldn't the police scenes I use a lot
of footage and there was some beautiful
moments where Matt he's very intuitive
to Europeans as Philip as a director and
like she could be lying on the floor
like talk gives the actors to help them
coach them and so I I had like a mind
stuff that I could find a beautiful
moment where Paul King looked as Molly
or Holly Molly Windsor and I could just
use that for that moment particularly in
the scene when she finally says if
anyone hasn't seen that she's charged
that the film opens with her being
charged with stealing two cans of pop
and a little bit like the crab actually
in script form that was all linear but
we ended up interweaving purely because
our episode was way too long it was 67
minutes and it was brilliant
[Music]
we had to collect things and interweave
and just find other solutions to try and
tell the story
so I'd say everyone was on point and
Paul Kane was just so beautiful and
revelation airy as the father that when
15 minutes into the film when the child
eventually says there go to charge here
and one of the Cubs leaves and all the
old police interviews were verbatim and
Nicole took some of the actual police
interviews then she just said I was
raped and for her father sitting there
and he had argued with her with her and
effectively told her to go
should go back to her friends as if she
was so happy there so the guilt and
remorse that Paul showed was just as
soon as I saw the brushes I just knew
that battles had to play as soon as she
said I was raped yet she had to see her
say those weren't because it took all
her courage to say it and then just to
see the father as he collapsed and his
rage he wanted to fight and of course
the building
thing I have to say is I met and
Philippa and Nicole and the team Suzanne
hug the producer and Susan Hawkins
Sounders they involved the real people
so I really have the privilege of
meeting the man who porque stars as and
when you meet the real people and you're
showing them the episode you feel just
such an abundance of responsibility to
do justice to their story and show the
conflict that they faced because they've
come through this heart and they were
very generous in their honesty to us to
help us tell the story and all the
actors were just brilliant so that goes
I was like little black players enjoyed
mines and all these beautiful frames
that say Philip as creators you know
what I think I forgive your contract
yeah and if you do that we all have to
come up and you're just thinking about
what what do you just said about like
looking at the tiny scenes and then
pulling back the incredible thing with
with some Harappan tone dark States is a
hole that I find really fascinating is
that you have these incredibly intimate
portraits of people but then you are
pulling far far back and saying okay
let's let's look at what's happening in
in this instance Virginia Virginia that
it is decimated are you if I'm not
mistaken you say one in five people have
some kind of addiction yeah I think that
and one in no three two in ten Bay
I think a ball says yes and what again
comes back to this idea of a perfect
balance of this is an incredibly
intimate documentary it's not what we
see as a conventional campaigning
documentary but at the same time it is
working on a level that says this is
such a dire situation that's only
getting worse how much of a challenge
was it to find that balance between the
personal and then this bigger issue it's
good question because across the three
programmes and dart States we had this
this challenge and originally there were
a lot more stories with the police or
with the fight so another police the
fire service this woman Jan was quite
character and initially Louie and on the
directs were very drawn to her and then
I remember in early conversations they
had Jan's great she's fantastic
she hardly ends up being in the film at
all and it was like like you know it's
saying we had to collapse a lot of a lot
of the fire service resuscitating people
we had to collapse them into these kind
of interstitial moments that then
hopefully provide a pace change and
allow you to then embed with the next
kind of emotional scene as we played it
back-to-back emotional scene or
emotional scene with these characters
who are still very much for living it it
would it would it would just be too much
so yeah it was it was something that
took quite a long time to get right and
actually the first program I cut was in
Milwaukee which is a gun violence woman
and that was even more of a challenge in
that program too so I still have
practice actually a gun violence is a
good moment to segue to the cut off a
kick-ass sequence in the opening of
episode 9 of peaky blinders which is
just quite extraordinary but again but
thing about people dying is people will
talk about I it is action-packed it's
amazing but it is driven by student
night's remarkable characterizations
it again what's it like trying to to cut
away from from the action down to the
quieter scenes in which there are many
in Egypt
yeah episode 3 is incredibly somber you
know it's it's all just people talking
across tables yeah apart from part from
the sequence where after kills two
people yeah there is a lot of quiet I
suppose I sort of I was quite nervous
about a peaky blinders because my I
wondered whether my style would sort of
fit this sort of house style which
there's been there have been obviously
lot you know across the last sort of
three series there have been six or so
editors and they've all brought their
own different styles to it all sort of a
feels of a piece you know it feels have
sort of unified but the way I like to
approach things in the way that
medicines the I assisted when I was an
assistant sort of taught me to do is to
try and tell the story in the most
simple and elegant way possible
and that suits those more sombre scenes
you know sort of I don't like when you
see everything whether whether the pace
is trying to be forced you know you do
have a lot of control over soar the
rhythm of the pace and as you can tell
if something is being amped up in order
to create sort of an effect but you know
it was a relief that everybody liked
what I was doing but so yeah in those
that when you're working with sort of
incredible performances like mcgrory and
it's killing the Murphy he just just
it's a joy you know you just have to let
them do their thing
so yes it's nice to have that contrast
though it's nicely you know you need
those sort of like top light and shade
so to have that yeah that these sort of
210 poles in the episode where you've
got this incredible sort of ballsy
streets out of the start and sort of the
doom-laden
foreboding at the end is sort of you can
you can forgive a little sort of
characterizations
you know the dog looks like you've
rewritten that and you do hang on every
word you you touched on other people
have edited previous episodes I don't
period I can bring you in on this as
well the challenge of actually coming
onto a project that has such a specific
strong identity and and how you kind of
deal with that perhaps P I'll start with
you obviously the person overseeing the
whole thing and the person writing it
that the same people so is it just
fitting in and is that fitting in quite
an easy thing to do well I also added it
the first season with Steven Daldry so
Peter and Steven work really well off
each other because they will confront
each other sometimes and disagree about
things and Steven will take for instance
the Nazi funeral episode 9 Peter came
into my room and said done I wrote one
line in the script and he gave me 9
minutes of material you know but that
material was outstanding and so I mean I
cut that scene with a lump in my throat
so it's trying to find trying to deliver
the script with a vision and and the
magic that Stephen shoes all the detail
that he shoots doesn't always get into
the film but when when it works it just
works really well and I have I mean some
of the some of the scripts on the crown
second season were standalone episodes
like episode 9 and like episode 8 which
is the other one I cut when the Kennedys
come to Buckingham Palace the tone of
that show was very comical and it
surprised me how as I read the script
you know I was laughing and enjoying it
and then by the end it really gets you
so Peter has this this way of getting to
the heart of the characters even through
comedy so even though the styles of the
shows and the directors have their own
vision it's
the same characters just in a different
part of their lives know something you
mentioned there but the look I can
documentary in the moment but the the
three narrative series was there ever a
discussion about this cinematic look of
what you were doing because I felt that
all three had were definitely a lot of
people talk about this so the way that
the television has aged towards cinema
in its visual style was did you have
discussions in fact to you first about
how it would look and I know it would be
edited as a result well it was more I
think the the overriding look has just
left I know she did the last one but
again she and I think I think that's
more that she just wanted to shoot so
she never did a conventional wide shot
to close up shop reversal it was just an
ever moving camera so even when we were
in the police investigation in Episode
two are in the court in Episode three
the only sort of concrete think that
ever sets me was in the course scenes
she just wanted it to be muddy and messy
like a documentary as if there's a
camera in that courtroom so you know you
got the lawyer and he's shuffling his
papers as opposed to a more traditional
TV drama night you could just have this
big wide shadows everyone stands up it's
all very contained if she just wanted it
real and messy and to feel in the shoes
of those people so but I think that was
the overriding note and I think cinema
came with it because once you just
embraced but you just wanted to tell the
story and whoever story you were farming
whether it was the police chief or you
had the girls themselves that the camera
was just always on their shoulder we
were in their shoes and that was then I
think that that was the style that was
reversed because from the footage we
have a lot of footage that we could play
with and just try and but it was always
different
yeah I think it's detrimental for a
director or producer to tell the editor
how to edit because um because then
you're missing out on a trip I mean an
editor comes to the material fresh
unbiased we're not on set usually we
don't know the arguments that have gone
on and who wants to do what who
disagrees with certain chador
or themes I actually went to an
interview many years ago and the
director said so um every night I'll be
sending you the time codes of the ins
and outs the beauty of working with
directors that you love and respect is
that they give you the material and they
want you to play with it they want you
to come up with something original and
you know on the occasion you might
disagree about one shot or one
performance but but it's all explained
and and in those cases you have to get
into their head and see what they're
trying to achieve and you work through
it but it's a collaboration and if they
want to give you a ton coats and they
may as well do it themselves or get an
assistant yeah absolutely I mean I know
point on peaky blinders did anybody tell
me how to cut anything it was sort of it
was David Caffrey was baring sort of not
hands off he was always around but he
was he could wage one things by him but
he he never interfered with this sort of
internal structure of the scene he was
happy with what I was doing which was
which was great so that then you move on
to the sort of the next stage is sort of
rewriting process you know sort of
sorting out problems of structure or or
massaging a performance to give us a
slightly different effect but yeah I
mean as PSS people that you work with
who you know they're onions they allow
you to get on with it and don't it over
your shoulder clicking their fingers
when you only want
yes I mean absolutely I think any any
director who does tell you to what the
time codes are I think is not good I
mean well it's not good for them but you
know when you get sitting on a dock you
get a script but sometimes pretty often
no because they haven't shot anything
yet so you get a sort of script like
Bowie we have a script and you look at
it you think oh what are the chapter
headings because the rest is all a work
of fiction because they need so so then
you say okay well that's the story and
then you kind of never look at it again
because we reacting to the material
you're getting I think that's the same
for you they go that's good so you say
you sit there and you watch this stuff
and you know it's your cue you're
thinking ah now that's us a good
connection there or I can do something
here you've got to react to the material
it's certainly in a documentary even a
bowi one where you had lots of
interviews I mean and the structure does
change because you could say oh well
that in paper goes from there to there
but when you when you put it together
with all the pictures you think now that
doesn't really work maybe we should try
this here and there so it's very fluid
so I think you know the director of a
documentary they most of them will not
tell you how to edit because in some
ways they didn't really know they know
roughly what the program is but they
kind of react to what's there and so you
know the the editing process is it is as
you say a collaboration it's not
satisfying actually but yeah it's the
chapters picked out if there is well did
strike me a halfway through watching
they were very the last five years the
this is someone who's been in public eye
since the late 1960s more than many
other people probably arguably anyone
else in his January
completely understood the power of the
image and there is a lot of material
regarding him yes and as well as having
so many interviews just just taking all
this material and actually chiseling
away and it must have taken a huge
amount of time yeah well I mean we had
10 weeks to edit that which is pretty
good for a dog but yeah it's but a lot
of the workers I mean to be fair on that
one there was hours of his radio and
voice interviews which luckily was all
transcribed so you could use that as
your interview material but sifting
through it was was go well we need him
to say this and doesn't ever say it
it would does say it well no one oh well
kind of go a different way you know it's
kind of it's it's that sort of thing
which hopefully nobody notices when they
see it but it's kind of yeah it's very
it's hard and I can imagine watching
some of the interviews was not
necessarily so enjoyable for you it's
very interesting watching this episode
harrowing time because it feels like you
are watching a documentary that's
comprised of certain chapters that
you're introduced to this new character
that adds another dimension to the
situation in this town but you're not
you don't then leave them they come back
later and and inform on the other
chapters that you've seen with with that
tough trying to sort of move these
characters in and out of each other's
lives
yes and it's the way is the way Louie
does tend to construct programs but
having said that I mean like I just like
to add it kind of relates to what Jen
was saying but I think that one of the
most interesting things about Louie in
particular as opposed to other
documentaries I've worked on is that
there's never really a plan it's just
like this in chat this is interesting
all right I'll just he'll read up and
then he'll just go and have an encounter
with someone and his
frustrating directors because I'm and me
as an editor will think oh this scene is
going to deliver this and they usually
do two shoots and then I started I saw
often start editing after the first one
and then the second one I'll be editing
while they're on the shoots that well
sometimes go can you get this if you go
back and see this person can we develop
it this way and then it'll go in a
completely different direction okay how
are you gonna factor in occasionally we
we cheat a little bit and we'll put so
there was a scene of a lake with a baby
we actually that actually happened the
scan happened after I think that he had
met her for the first time but I can't
we might even drop that scene but some
days you have to reorder how things
happened in time so that the story makes
more sense with that particular
character and then there's a lot of yes
shuffling around index cards so you know
it's again it's a lovely collaborative
process between me delirium and director
and we're all just enjoying this okay
let's do that
okay doing the day and we'll watch it
again and I know
interestingly talked about you can work
with working with France historically
he's a lovely man and I did a couple of
documentaries with him and he said I've
got I've got this idea for the opening
shot of the film
I'll get this craning and we'll put lots
of televisions and smoke and this was
for a motor break move we'll film The
Supremes on it and I'll go through there
we'll have Berry Gordy's voice talking
and yes sounds great so he shot it and
we some looks like yeah that's just
thought we're never gonna use this it's
like yeah okay we'll put it in and I
live stayed in the cut right up until
the last week of the idea when Ronnie
said Frances just doesn't work
[Laughter]
but that's that's you know that's the
joy of his beat that was the main thing
and that's kind of great really you know
really rare to get it's nice it's a very
interesting thing about reordering and
what you were talking about and in a way
it's it's not about staying with what is
but actually realizing the whether it's
documentary or narrative filmmaking it's
trying to achieve some kind of emotional
truth yeah but for instance the kraang
is a really fascinating example of I
don't necessarily believe everything in
it is exactly how it was but I
understand the end game of what you're
trying to do what you're trying to
represent with that series you're about
to tell me now that everything is I mean
after I read the scripts I just googled
everything because I didn't know a lot
of the history and especially the
background of Phillip and his his whole
the whole plane crash and the family
history so it was fascinating and
although I'm from the Commonwealth and
I've seen the Queen's image every day of
my life working on the show and learning
more about the history has given me more
understanding of the family and more
respect for what they go through
I don't come back to you with this idea
this truth we working with Louis have
there ever been bound erease if anyone
have you seen the outside it's probably
the most shocking piece of television an
unexpected piece of television I've seen
in the last year we're not using the
words that Dewey and the guy uses but it
says to guy have you ever performed
fellatio no I've just received it for
money to buy drugs and it's one of those
wonderful things about Luther oh I think
yeah I know how far you'll go no he goes
further
is there is there a discussion about
boundaries or materially and and who is
very sensitive about that we have yeah
it's a I think it's really yeah it's one
of those kind of liminal zones well
which which is what party why I love
working on Louie is how and sometimes
he'll go no I think we went a bit far on
that you know there may be some moments
of quorum ever exactly in heroin town
where there was some moments maybe of
humor and we thought no that's that's
going a bit too far but it's certainly I
mean I think that's why people love him
because he does come up with these you
know moments but but we also we have to
sort of prune them you know make sure
that that doesn't hide that it's really
not about him and he's always very very
sensitive that it's this and I feel very
sensitive and kind of responsible that
you have a duty of kahi's a really good
journalist and I think we all see
ourselves as journalists not in a
particularly worthy way but in you know
you talk about emotional truth and I
think that's what I tried to do with in
every scenes so I might restructure
certain looks and pauses and I you know
most scenes they were kind of an hour
long and then they boiled down to five
or six minutes but within that I think
we're all conscious of distilling some
kind of truth about that encounter and
the humor often bringing peering people
people really respond to you and that's
why the contributors feel safe I think
and I think wisdom do feel safe and this
is big fascinating thing with three
girls that again you're telling a real
life story because you also presenting
the drama yes exactly and sometimes I
think people might think that the drama
is sort of contained but when you're
doing a drama like three girls we found
for example in Episode two
we had to do a lot of restructuring
because we realized that in the script
we were saying that they were the first
police to break the story and then three
weeks into the end of the cult cadence
in
Philip have found is grouping Rotherham
had gone first so we had to create
because of course they finished the
shoes and there's no more money to shoot
so there was two scenes that we had to
create from nothing one of them was the
scene in episode 2 where we over a night
we just put all the names of all the
cities who have suffered this on street
grooming and in episode 3 Sara Rowbotham
she heard that the police were done
denying that she had handed over
information when she was driving in the
car and filled by myself which was
trying to work out how could we do
justice to that because we discovered
this after the shooting but we luckily
had three weeks per episode they gave us
a little bit more because we're to show
the contributors and in Episode two Sara
have driven and ruby to the abortion
clinic so we just cheated the shot so
she wouldn't documentary without it from
blink of an eye and freeze and I mean
download the real interview on one hour
and just try to create the truth of what
actually happened as opposed to taking
liberties with have Sara Suki because
for Sara that was really important she
heard that on the radio no one gave her
the courtesy of coming in and took it to
her director so that was really
important for us to try to fabricate
that and any material that we had shot
four previous episodes or previous
scenes so I think that's I think that's
why I love asking because you can tell
the story in crafts and I have a
documentary background so I love that
idea that you can you can find the way
to truthfully tell the story in really
creative ways and bringing the emotional
heart back to the film I want to open
the floor in a moment but before I do
fill up this final comment woman we had
the directors to the audience was to ask
how many female directors are in the
audience and quite a few put their hands
up she said to everyone in the room you
have to make sure more women working in
the industry um it's great that this
family is dominated by women it's
refreshing and positive so with that in
mind perhaps it is it's too big or have
you a question to ask the three of you
but would you what advice would you give
aspiring female editors or what advice
would you give generally about the
industry and perhaps as well I would
actually love to see just a better
representation of all of us because
we're such a multiracial country as well
and I feel that that has not been
reflected in our industry and whether
it's through the education or in schools
or just promoting community projects
pouring money into communities for
people to be able to find their way to
tell story because I feel that
filmmaking and storytelling for anyone
who maybe isn't coming from a very
wealthy background it's a way to express
yourself and it's such a shame not to
see more people from all walks of life I
come from a not wealthier from a very
working-class background and the only
reason I could actually go to where I am
now it's because my uncle lived in
London I was able to stay with him free
so school back in 95 I see by the way a
brilliant therapist Bryson who was in my
class and and same thing only that the
European Union breakfast paid for
everything
I wouldn't feel able to go mom dad I was
glad to help me with rent and things
like that because no you have to pay
fees I mean it's just I'm from Arlington
in Arlington University up at recently
was free for everyone and now they're
bringing in his fees that tried to
follow of the model which they shouldn't
be following this model should be
getting more people into absolutely
vital to pay trainings properly yeah
yeah the BBC luckily I was one of those
people who was old enough to been on the
BBC training scheme as an assistant
editor and gosh it's it was great but
they really doesn't need to be something
like that but now because I think it's
really hard to get together foothold in
getting known without somebody you know
getting accustomed and being able to go
in there and do something you know and
just see how it works and also the
technology plays a part in this too
because I started cutting out the
cutting film and it was very interactive
in that the editor would mark the film
and I would physically cut it together
when I was an assistant so you're you're
physically cutting the film together and
you're in the same room now we're in
separate rooms they're on computers
doing technical things and and I'm doing
the creative stuff so I do encourage my
assistants to edit the scenes I would
critique them and I think assistants
have to work even harder than you ever
imagined possible
because it's the only way to get the
practice and and I do allow trainees to
come and sit with me for a day here and
there I take something very funny
because I was working on the credit too
as well and our assistant Esther's two
of them made their own films in the damn
time one of them did a feature like I
thought I mean how did they make this
medicine as a class and with his
girlfriend that every would active and
it was brilliant and the other guy did a
short film and so I engage and Ben
senior bone and the two guys they made
these brilliant films and when I saw
them and danced your film won awards and
I was saying that's what you want you
won't just because technology has become
more accessible you even do it on your
phone to whatever you like and just try
and make your film sense cinemas shows
your films before big films bring that
back show those student films with big
features why not well I interesting we
after had
Walter Murch here a couple of weeks ago
and overheard a conversation he had with
a young student where he said look in my
day I did not go up to the Francis Ford
Coppola of of the 1960s to look for a
job Francis Ford Coppola was just down
here there yeah and I started working
with him then find the person who's
starting out that you can work with
within that team and work out with them
navigate been wiser
we should really open the floor to any
questions or comments that people have
so we have any hands up high so all
these shows and films that are
absolutely amazing and right at the top
level and a lot of people and I'm kind
of like at the bottom level doing like
indie feature films and you can't seem
to get to the next level and I've been
in situation where similar people just
think that I am working on not hands are
too little budget for them to consider
me and is there any kind of guys that
you might you can you can give me on I
mean like I said I don't like I said
before I'm not as established as sooner
and Pierre or not I make the
breakthrough cutting about sort of ten
or eleven maybe actually probably sort
of twelve years ago and it's only in the
last couple of years I've started to
work on things that I feel live into and
I've and I'm enjoying and noting her
great so it does take a long time it
really does you just have to keep any
opportunity that comes your way I mean I
got gorilla because I was asked to do a
recap on John the director John Ridley's
film about Jimi Hendrix it was like a
couple of weeks work and I I ended up
being on it for about six weeks I ended
up having to do other things like a
title sequence and bloody boat about but
really I was an additional editor that
was my credit but that led to me getting
the job on gorilla so you just have to
suck up those little opportunities and a
connection will be made and you'll
and you'll get the break just have to
keep plugging away that's the anyway
give you laughs well I'm currently doing
a very low but doesn t films even when
you do something they're still there but
I would say producers producers give
people break just don't pigeonhole of
you and hopefully if you keep working I
keep telling people you're working even
though I see people to prison them
online you think you just get your films
out there create your website and put
your films out there and hopefully
you've got a break producers have got to
be more courageous because say as a
trauma if sir so I was a documentary I'm
sorry I had to make the beeper to drama
scene then I mean CBS you now try to get
its a feature film acting and it's like
these walls this constant walls so you
have to use keep keep going but tell
everyone if you have your film and you
meet someone you give them the link or
do anything you can to try and just let
people know if you're if you decide to
assist for sure well tell you register
that you want to add it and most
abstruse I think the very gracious and
give any help that they can recommend
getting into TV as well because there's
so much there was a lot of work around
at the moment yeah TV don't tell them
even if it's a really formulaic
low-budget things worth doing because
the directors who might be doing that
will be doing something else yeah I mean
Ben Karen who's now I think series
director on the crap I work with him
back on this I won't even say what it
was but it was this really it was
reality TV yeah like going places but
you know in later it where he is yeah
and it's those people that you meet I'd
say also be restless so don't stay I've
jumped about from you know I do it a lot
of formats back in the day and you just
have to kind of go no I look and I'm
bored with this now I'm gonna try
something else and you take those
opportunities and those go with those
people and also I think my my advice to
anyone is trust your instincts if the
script is brilliant and they've got very
little money it's really worth doing I
think rather than if the script is not
brilliant and it's very firmly here
don't do it because as editors if
there's problems in the script they will
come to the cutting room and if you're
working and we've all done it
I'm owed so much money from historical
work but I will never see that when you
work with that because I'm paid properly
people really take advantage of you
because your work isn't valued by them
so then I am stopped I was doing like 72
hours 80 hours a week and when I looked
back as I was thinking what was I doing
in my 20s I was just working so hard to
try to make films and then the producer
might come and say sorry with no money
can't pay you you've just done all this
work you're like oh my god so I would
say trust your instincts if the script
is great and it's worth doing to it but
if the script is not great
proceed with caution because as people
be the ones dealing with that times when
you don't have a choice for you know I
know that's why I think your attic TPS
is a good option and that's it's a
really great script just be always got
time for one more question
in that case oh right down at the front
if you wait for the microphone thank you
do you think that technology and the way
that we shoot films now digitally
instead of on film has changed the way
directors work how they do coverage and
is there a bit more of a thought oh well
we'll just shoot the [ __ ] out of it and
then we'll fix it in post
I mean you know yes absolutely
certainly adults they kind of do shoot
the [ __ ] out you reframe the stabiliser
so good but yeah it has I think
personally this is in my opinion that
it's a it's different if it's a knob
talk or something going and shooting
everything that moves doesn't
necessarily mean you're gonna come up
with something and I think you know you
kind of hope the director has an idea of
what the story is that they're following
I mean if you're doing a knob job you
need a camera person that can follow it
you can't direct that you need somebody
you can follow what's happening so they
you know shooting everything is not
going to make it work so I think it's I
think as long as people have an idea
what it's what will it bought the story
they're telling is it'll work yeah but I
think the technology has helped me to
get my vision across better because you
could easily do speed changes and
steadying shots and some visual effects
that allow you to edit better so that so
that I'm getting what I want and also
the sound design it starts on my first
assembly and music as well I mean what
we kind of have to put some score
because execs don't really get the film
without it but but at least we have a
choice of creating that tone of the
music with other soundtracks and sound
effects helps so much so for me it's
it's a godsend
well actually the the Wow can do we have
time I'm doing something now and I
decided that that the year and place and
time was very important and integral to
the story so I put these big captions
and I never would have been able to do
that on the film so I have them whizzing
across the screen and fading up and so
it's part of the narrative and so yeah
all of that helps I guess that if the
panel's yet
music oh yeah they actually recorded the
band's playing in a corner you're
absolutely right about the soundtrack
because you know if you're editing
whether it's any documentary music pay
attention to the soundtrack because it's
got a work because when you get into the
dub and you kind of see that oh blimey
that's a terrible edit or whatever you
can't it's a bit late to fix it then so
yeah but the music pros are problems but
always be aware of the sound I think is
it though you're right makes such a big
difference if you get that kind of level
of how have the effects come up here all
the violence here get it all in the
customer because you're right
most of most a execs probably they say
oh I'll say I'll watch a film with black
holes and those dancers get pay
attention to every bit sound and
pictures I think it's very important and
we do that well Stephen Daldry does that
but on television the editors are let go
at picture lock and most of the
directors I work with fight to keep me
on to the end of the mix because nobody
knows the film better than the editors
and although they want to save money
it's a pulse saving because the mix the
sound we know how its constructed we
know every little frame of it so I think
that's very always trying at least if
you're not kept on at least go along to
a mix with news yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
no conflicting advice here what okay
fortunately we are going to have to draw
this to a close thanks to BAFTA for
organizing this event but most of all
can you please join me in thanking our
guest today
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]